[Music]
it's known as The Pinnacle of Motorsport
the fastest the most technically
Advanced with a long glamorous yet
sometimes controversial and checkered
history
and more than 70 years since the first
race Formula One is undergoing a Kind of
Revolution new rules new tech new teams
and a surge in popularity but what does
it take to build an F1 team
to find out we're leaving the drivers on
the track to go behind the scenes at
McLaren HQ they're celebrating their
60th anniversary and trying to rebuild
into a championship winning team this is
Zach Brown a former racing driver who
then founded the world's biggest
Motorsports marketing agency when he
joined McLaren as CEO in late 2016 the
car and the business were both
struggling to compete
morale was was very poor everything was
really poor you know when I entered it
was our worst year in the history of
McLaren finishing ninth in the
championship we had very little uh in
the way of sponsorship we had really
lost our our way we were a struggling
Formula One team
McLaren's Glory Days were in the 80s and
90s with drivers like Alan plus and
Ayrton Senna it hasn't won the
Constructors Championship since 1998 and
the drivers Championship since 2008 with
Lewis Hamilton winning brings Glory more
prize money and bigger commercial deals
in 2022 McLaren finished a disappointing
fifth out of the current list of 10
teams and parted ways with Daniel
Ricardo after the driver team
combination failed to live up to its
promise
but Brown says they've come a long way
I now fast forward we have a car with
some of the best Partners in the world
the Google's coca-colas Dells Cisco
Goldman Sachs we're back to winning
races at this point it's only been one
close call in uh one other race but
we're getting back towards the front
2017 Liberty Media became f1's new
owners in an 8 billion dollar deal under
the American Media Group revenues have
increased 1.8 billion dollars in the
first nine months of 2022 versus 1.5
billion dollars in the same period in
2019 the year before the pandemic hit
they've introduced a number of changes
designed to make racing more competitive
and to entice new manufacturers and
investors
these changes include a cost cap for
spending on the car which was reduced to
135 million dollars this year
I think a cost cap was was critical uh
all these Formula One teams were losing
a lot of money and it was kind of a game
of who can afford to lose the the most
you see the value of these franchise now
growing rapidly as they should be on par
with the NFLs and the Premier League
teams given the size and stature of our
sport
in F1 the drive has attract a lot of the
hype McLaren will be relying on 23 year
old British Belgian racing driver Lando
Norris and rookie Australian oscar
piastri but what about the rest of their
700 strong team
in the race Bay mechanics are building
the new car
teams keep their attack top secret so
we're told not to film under the show
I'm Johnny Brooks the director of
Formula One build here at McLaren our
race really starts as soon as the
checkered flag Falls at the previous
race the cars get back here as quickly
as possible we do everything that we
need to do to the cars upgrade them swap
parts out reliability fixes and then we
get the cars back out to the race team
where they get built up at the track
[Music]
Spencer Ford head of metallic Machining
and additive Manufacturing in the
Machine Shop they make all the metal
components for the card
so we have a mix of five axis machines
and also multitasking blades and we use
a variety of those to make the parts and
the most appropriate fastest way we can
parts for the Bodywork suspension
gearbox from the smallest washer to the
largest suspension component
in this clean room the team is producing
carbon fiber components using the
chassis wings and gearboxes
my name is rosford I am the director of
Composites manufacturing at McLaren
racing anything produced out of carbon
fiber we can do in this room it's quite
a simple process we do lots of it
through layers and layers of prepreg
carbon fiber it's built up with lots of
thin layers of carbon we lay them on one
on top of the other in an organized
manner we cook them in a large pressure
cooker and they'll come out and we'll
get solid carbon fiber components that
we can then use to make fast light very
strong parts for our Formula One Cup
the final step is laminating where the
all-important sponsorship stickers are
added nowadays they use vinyl wrap not
paint it saves on weight but also makes
the design adaptable
the sticker on the car is almost to let
everyone know that we have this great
partnership but what goes on behind the
scenes the amount of business that we've
driven for our business to business
partners introducing them to governments
and other Fortune 500 companies to you
know to do a lot of business with them
or ourselves to helping them build their
brand
Andrea Stella is McLaren's New team
principal
so what's his role
you have to make sure that these are 700
people are all aligned in what is the
vision the mission what the objectives
and all this needs to be incredibly
simply stated make sure that everyone is
on the same page
under Liberty Media the vision of F1 is
expansion building on a global fanbase
human rights groups have criticized the
sports decision to host races in Qatar
and Saudi Arabia as it pushes into the
Middle East with accusations of sports
washing but F1 also has its sights on
the US this year a Las Vegas Grand Prix
is on the calendar to add to Miami and
Austin
and the number of U.S viewers is on the
up the sports has also been boosted by
the Netflix show drive to survive which
Taps into the drama on and off the track
2022 represents a new dawn performance
the biggest overhaul that the
regulations have ever had
why the fans have responded and we found
so many new fans is we've let people in
behind the scenes of what how actually a
Formula One team operates there's always
an element of emotions and passions that
that drive individuals I'm sure drive to
survive is playing this element in the
new generation which is great to see
thank you
it's not just the drivers who thrive on
passion and competition at McLaren HQ
everyone is working with the aim of
taking on leading Constructors Red Bull
Ferrari and Mercedes
the stakes are high U.S Investment Group
MSP Sports capital is putting 185
million pounds into McLaren to help fund
their return to the top it's allowed the
team to spend on the new wind tunnel to
develop the aerodynamics of the car
but the tunnel isn't ready just yet and
will take time to pay off foreign
capitalizing on your potential simply
you cannot be competitive to score
podiums or win a formula one we always
have to constantly look at ways that you
can get a competitive advantage on the
other teams and everyone is trying to do
that and it's not just technical it can
be Politics as well if someone's got
something you decide whether you protest
it or you copy it you're a competitor in
a really competitive world-class Sport
and if you if you are not running all of
the time you're just standing still and
if you're standing still in Formula One
you're at the back of the grid so it is
Relentless all the time things get
heated but that's the nature of what we
do just like the drivers are in
competition with each other I'm in
competition with the build director of
other teams we get judged every two
weeks on our performance which is unique
in in business the whole team's really
excited to see their parts performing on
track and obviously running reliably so
we are probably the really fast legs
under the pond when a duck swimming and
and you only ever see the the beautiful
duck at the circuit but yeah we are
running really fast here collaboratively
working together to make sure this all
happens and they can go and race cars
each weekend it's a hundred lap duel
scenic but dangerous F1 is a sport where
history becomes Legend but what of the
Future Ford will re-enter The Fray in
2026 it's hoping to Showcase its
technology as rules on Net Zero exhaust
emissions come into play and F1 as a
whole has pledged to go Net Zero by
2030.
however it's not clear how this can be
achieved not only because of race
emissions but also because of the carbon
footprint caused by f1's huge traveling
circus moving people cars and equipment
by land sea and air to more than 20
races around the world
one thing that is clear is that if
McLaren is going to start winning
championships it needs to develop as
well as race faster than the competition
trying to close the gap to catch our
competition means we're gonna have to
actually out develop them because
they're not sitting still you actually
need to start thinking about the 26 car
that's where we want to put the team in
condition to have more capacity to deal
with these challenges because that's
what's required if you want to compete
at the top
history Echoes through the sport
but it takes fast legs under the water
to keep the team heading in the right
direction for the future